ladies and gentlemen connecting the dots
on crime
isn't always an easy thing sometimes you
want a nice
neat narrative to answer all your
questions and the reality is
such a narrative doesn't really exist
and when that happens
it's incumbent on us to set the record
straight
to do the digging no one else wants to
do
the story we're setting straight today
was actually talked about
yesterday on this channel the story of
defy 100 a crypto coin
which allegedly exit scammed everybody
and left a page
on their website saying that we scammed
all of you and you can't do [ __ ] about
it
new details have come out including fake
doxes revenge developers
and the actual person in charge of it
denying all these claims
have come out and i want to examine all
of them today with you
to find out who's innocent and who's
guilty ladies and gentlemen
welcome to the 10 million dollar studio
i am coffeezilla the internet detective
and today
we're talking about d5 100 again we
talked about this yesterday
but some really big massive breaks in
the case
came out yesterday after i had made the
video
and i want to talk to you guys about
them today to make sure that we're all
on the same page
because the last thing i want to do is
leave you with misinformation
unclarified unexamined now let's start
from the beginning
yesterday a website selling defy 100
tokens
put up this image on their website and
quickly
crypto accounts began reporting on this
the most notable was mr whale who said
breaking defy 100 coin exit scams and
runs away
with 32 million dollars in investor
funds but personally i was interested in
finding out who was responsible for this
i told everyone if you have a tip who
the developer might be my dms are open
i've been trying to hunt them down
all morning i also warned everyone that
someone had already been
falsely doxed because he was thought to
be in connection with d5 100 but he
wasn't
he just forked the github repo and as an
aside
don't dox people unless you're sure that
they're actually part of something
because i've seen now
multiple doxxing of the developers that
i don't think they actually were the
main guy and i actually got the person
who first leaked this
docs to remove it because it wasn't
actually the guy that they thought it
was
but anyway i said uh i said this and i
got a response
logo blog claimed that he was the
developer of defy 100's website
and he had to put the message up to
bring out the developers from
hiding and then he gave his telegram
handle right here
kiss my axe now at the same time this
was happening defy 100's official
twitter account which
last tweeted on march 15th also went
public and started posting things
on may 23rd they said the website was
hacked yesterday and the message
was shown by the hackers it has been
taken down
in response to this crypto whale says
they were doxxed and now are trying to
claim they were hacked
nice try to cover it up no one believes
it
but i wanted to investigate it anyways
so i contacted this guy bloggo blog
which i kind of expected to be a troll
or something like that i got a lot of
troll accounts telling me that they were
connected or they knew who this guy was
and of course they ended up not
but i feel like i have to chase down you
know a lot of these rabbit holes anyway
just to see where they go
so i got on telegram and i actually
messaged this guy
i said you sent a twitter message saying
you're the admin of their wordpress can
you prove that
i was yes lol i'll send you screenshots
of chats
with devson now bear in mind devson is
the develo the original guy
the lead suspect in our defy 100 case
and he said he developed their website
so of course i asked for proof because
this is pretty extraordinary because
he's claiming
to have put up the message that they
scammed everybody he responds with the
chat log between himself
and devson the profile now i immediately
checked
and that is the guy's actual profile
picture
but then i found something that even
further corroborated his story
this screenshot from the official
telegram group of d100
where devson himself claims that kiss my
axe is updating
the website he messaged me earlier to
show the site he developed so far
wow this is actually a massive break in
the case we still don't know who devson
is
but now we know who's responsible for
posting this message of we scammed you
guys
and you can't do about it now
interestingly he signs off
devson but now he's saying that actually
it was him
that put up the message the guy who
originally made the website
so i have asked of course why would you
do that he responds that basically
for two months the project was dead and
the guy had basically abandoned
the project and when the project began
to fail he had originally offered to do
website work for free
he completed the website for them and
basically was trying
to launch the coin but devson stopped
responding after waiting two months
seems like he got tired and decided it
was his job to bring devson
to justice now at this point i'm
wondering a lot of things about this
guy's motives
uh why he would do this so of course i
asked him did if he lost money in the
project he said yes
and i asked how much apparently twelve
thousand dollars or in finance token uh
30 b so this is a disgruntled developer
who's working on this project for free
and the original guy who started the
whole project has it basically
abandoned it and so he posts something
it sounds like to try to get a bunch of
like attention to it and try to make the
guy come out of hiding or whatever
by saying that basically they scammed
everybody and signing it off as the guy
i of course asked this person if he
thought that devson had scammed everyone
and he said this he is a loser who is
technically poor and can't manage what
he started
of course he has made money but then he
bailed when he couldn't handle community
pressure
it's kind of and this is his words a
soft drug pull so if i'm reading this
right he's saying
this guy got way in over his head took
the money and ran
i'd call that a scam but it definitely
complicates his motives now
interestingly
he still is anonymous even to this
internal developer
i asked him if he knew who it was he
said no and then he said he even tried
to put an
ip tracker at one point when he wanted
to know where this guy was but the guy's
ip
couldn't be recording he must be hiding
it which is a perfect segue for our
sponsor today
express people no i'm just kidding
little youtube sponsorship
joke guys very very hot very hot anyways
the guy was hiding his ip
which to me once again that further
implicates him i mean yes the story's
gotten complicated
but it definitely seems like this guy
knew things could go wrong and wanted to
protect himself
if things did go wrong this devson guy
if you're hiding if you're anonymous
we have to ask why if you're masking
your ip from even your own developers
and that's why i said smart if he knew
he was scamming so that's basically
where we are now
d100 has basically denied this saying
that the website was hacked
but that's not entirely true it was a
real developer for the project
the website guy uh who just got annoyed
because he had lost tons of money with
the project and the guy had ditched the
project and he decided to basically draw
a bunch of attention to it with this
bombastic post
and i thought you know we have to
explain exactly what's happened
defy 100 has gone on to say that the
real losses to investors were smaller
than originally reported
rumors of scamming 32 mil are false and
baseless and then he talks about the
market cap
but one thing that pisses me off is that
this person says there is no exit scam
and we're still working on finding a way
to bring the project back on its feet
and to this i have to say
no you're not stop lying okay if your
last tweet from this account before you
got
publicly called out was march 15th
you're done with the project right you
left in march 15th
you weren't gonna suddenly come back you
didn't suddenly feel bad
for everybody if the one of your main
website developers
says he hasn't been in touch with you
for two months you were done with the
project
you feel bad because you got caught out
but you were done with the project
so i really hate to see this back
pedaling or whatever and
you know what this developer he's
anonymous you can't trust him no matter
what
especially if he tries to start a new
coin or something saying he's gonna make
everyone's money back
do not trust him do not believe him
anyways
uh that's basically it that concludes
the we scammed you guys and you can't do
about it saga ladies and gentlemen it's
been a journey
stories of revenge false doxings i mean
you have everything
the the guy coming in denying it saying
we were hacked that sort of being true
but also sort of being not true
this story has been a wild ride uh but
either way i hope you didn't lose money
i hope you were smart thanks for
watching and i'll see you guys
in the next one
wake up and smell the coffee